is it correct that J Edgar Hoover could
tell so much about someone from Simply a
handshake yeah absolutely uh every time
that he went to shake people's hands he
was investigating whether they were
telling the truth
so if they were not telling the truth he
may notice the temperature in the body
was changing and maybe that there might
be some sweat coming out
he was incredibly sensitive so when we
worked on J Edgar Hoover with um
Leonardo
he wanted all of that to be there I mean
he is a perfectionist
so he he did
research on his life extreme research
but then he wanted to bring it into the
physical level and that's where I came
in I came in to help and get that
preciseness so for example the way that
Leo walks is very somewhat relaxed
and he's kind of an athlete so you know
he has an athletic gate
but he wanted a J Edgar Hoover that
every step he was rooted exactly he was
really grounded
and so we worked on that we worked on on
his walking on his sitting we worked on
how he opened doors we we walked on how
he shook people's hands and he went to
such level that he would wear the
costume and the makeup
and then he would have someone sort of
do some tests
and and then check it with me whether it
was all convincing
and then also he did uh you know it
started from him being in his 20s going
all the way into 60s so there was we
mapped out the aging process
and as time went on did J Edgar Hoover
fold into himself yeah uh his health was
not good and so we wanted to get all
that elements of Health
and he was getting some shots
that you know to speak
basically speed for him to do what he
was doing
and uh and how would that reflect in
behavior and movement and
so we got all of that precision and uh
it was fantastic really
um it helps when the actor wants that
kind of precision in the body
and then if you looked at Leo as a Frank
Abagnale
also sort of a light gate and and quick
and things like that but a different
maybe uh demeanor you know because the
different side of the law
um maybe a little I don't know if you
remember the movie but yeah yeah just
was did you see how the body changed yes
he changes his body he changes his
dialect he changes his voice so some
some actors are very much into complete
transformation
and they do it they go and do it and
it's magnificent uh Meryl Streep is uh
famous for this
uh where she transforms herself
completely you don't even she's
unrecognizable
but she does it because there is that
kind of immersion and full
transformation
but it does take time
it takes desire
it takes knowledge because I think that
you really do have to be willing to go
that far
you know to to become a you know
different person altogether
but in a truthful way and uh rather than
in a um just the makeup and just the
costume you know but really changing
what the body is doing
why do you say that the body is a
musical instrument because it is
it is
um our body well I'll compare my body to
a cello
uh the strings of the cello are really
that part of us that vibrates
with our life and vibrates with
intention
right so to in order to for the cello to
have that kind of music is that that
they have to be very very tuned and they
have to be and the whole cello begins to
vibrate so the body uh the body of the
child of the wooden part the wooden
casing of the cello is our bones so
every bone including my head my head my
rib cage my pelvis
uh my arms and my legs we call them
sympathetic
uh
vibrations because they're connected to
but everything in my body is vibrating
including my back
and that kind of that kind of use
really is very much like a musical
instrument
and what do you get in a musical
instrument you get all the pitches
all the rhythms
and guess what we can have that too we
can have that variation of sound
singers can do that opera singers are
magnificent and some actors you know
um I've always thought that President
Obama had a beautiful voice
and but I think it came from his use
he was quite free
in his you know great basketball player
and you've seen it too in musicians that
their performances on stage the front
man of a band Roger Daltrey or uh Robert
Plant or you know the way they move
around absolutely absolutely they're
totally free and vibrant it's very
exciting we have a quote here
actors often spend too much time
focusing on making their bodies into
hard armor and not enough on discovering
an emotional life
I think that's from
uh your Tech Works Facebook page so the
Alexander Tech workspace and I'm not
sure if this was Kristoff who had said
yeah uh what that means is a lot of
actors in Hollywood they work very hard
to get fit and be body beautiful right
and if you look and it's
whether they want to do work and for
Marvel and you know superheroes or that
they they are going to show skin
you know they don't want to be flabby or
anything so uh and it's women and men
and the problem with that is that if you
work out so much
that uh you have developed an armor in
your body and so it's hard to express
so if if the character gets depressed
it's harder to uh allow the depression
to come in or the emotions to come in
or the vulnerability you know that often
actors have to open up their windows and
doors and
and let the audience in how do you do
that you know but if you have all that
tension
that presentation so to speak because in
a way mus muscles present the person a
certain way
which is not necessarily a bad thing I
mean sometimes it can be kind of fun but
but it's limiting let's put it that way
it's very limiting
sure and it seems like we focus so much
on the outer that how could anybody be
depressed it's like a mask a very nice
mask indeed but then it is possible to
have both you know that you can still
work out but don't do it so much that
you're so stiff you know do it to a
um a reasonable amount
the quote I have acting is a visceral
activity
body should be infused with energy
breath and
of the character
yes
amen that was Kristoff yeah yeah okay so
what does that mean visceral
um so often often we are not aware of
what's going on inside of us of
ourselves you know and definitely in our
culture uh people do not want
to reveal what's really going on on the
inside
but that the best acting is when we can
feel directly from your gut what's going
on and then we believe the the character
you know I'm thinking about I I Tonya
Margot Robbie was excellent Beyond
Beyond
good because she allowed that part of
her that anger and that uh abandonment
and abuse that she had as a child and in
her life
and she let it out so beautifully but so
it is it is happening in the organs
so yes we do have to train the body to
such degree that we can use our organs
and our blood
often I say to people
um I I want your blood into this and
they get it they say oh god I didn't
even think about my blood but that's
that's what makes a performance
um heightened
brings it up it really does
so yes so that's that's what that means
that you know we've we learn to see how
it opens up the character from the
inside out
and why this or visceral or visceral
it's because it sustains us and it's
it's the hunger
right or it's the uh the pain of the
heart
you know again it's an organ
it feels it that way and the
most people have told me that usually
when they work this way it's it's an
adventure for them uh it's kind of
terrifying for a lot of them
but the result on screen is
Unforgettable
you want to give that that the organs to
the character
and um and yes you will feel like you've
really done something
extraordinary and you will be tired
uh after doing shooting a movie for 10
weeks this way
um
but then you know then you get the
recognition that
Margot Robbie gets you know so people
notice
definitely
and you said with the character the
Tonya Harding character put the anger
and and the abuse but also became a
gazelle when I was when it was Showtime
right well she was not a gazelle she was
actually a pit bull she was a pitbull
and she was a wild horse
um okay a stallion or something yeah
yeah when when I was employed by her uh
the the director was complaining that
she uh she was through light
and and
and the uh Tonya Harding was more
muscular and heavier
and more somewhat more brutal in her
approach to skating and and and Margot
wasn't getting it it wasn't happening so
so that's when I came in and I I and I
got her to do some animal work
so I usually tell people to study
one or two animals that feel like the
character why too because usually we
have two people inside of us you know we
might be one way at work and then
at home we may be completely in a
different way
so she picked up two animals
and she studied them and she collected
photographs
and and I I put them through a process
of transformation into the animal
so they know how the animal eats how the
animal attacks how the animal runs
how the animal breathes right and then
gradually we
begin to bring it to human form
so we may do you know 50 50
horse 50 percent human and then I say oh
okay now 75 human 25 horse what what are
you going to keep maybe it's the way
that the horse stops maybe it is the way
the horse gazes the in its environment
maybe it's a quality in in the sound of
the horse
so um
But ultimately uh what you see on screen
is just basically Maybe
10 5 of the animal
but it just gives them so much freedom
once they found that heaviness you know
or that wildness
from the animal
it's really or even the focus of an
animal bless them that boy are they
focused
on survival
much more focused than we are as humans
much more focused